hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video we're going to speak about
and break down the rumor of tom cruise
playing a variant of iron man and the
upcoming doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness film now it is
expected that multiple actors will be um
playing variants of popular characters
such as iron man now um if tom cruise is
playing iron man this would be a nod
when tom cruise was actually considered
for the role of iron man for the first
film before robert was cast design man
now we have some leaked images here
which people have been using as proof
that his character is indeed an upcoming
multiverse of madness film but i believe
these images are fake and i'm going to
break down and explain to you why soon
as images here fans have pointed out
that these images look very similar to
some previous images of doctor strange
and fan of so look at the first images
here of tom cruise in the mocap suit it
looks very similar to the mocap suit
used for thanos now if you look at his
head it looks like it's obviously been
photoshopped in but the main thing to um
take note of is the mocap suit like it
looks absolutely identical to the one
that josh used for thanos but if you're
still not convinced i think the second
image will convince you now we have this
image of tom cruise in front of a green
screen here now if we look at the image
of doctor strange you can see the green
screen environment is exactly the same
you got the camera in the exact same
position you got the lights above the
stage here the roof is the same
everything is identical in this image
apart from it being cropped a little bit
and obviously doctor strange been
removed and tom cruise being added in so
if you're still not convinced there is
this reliable scooper known as um big
screen leaks and a fan asked them if um
tom cruise was an upcoming doctor
strange in a multiverse of madness film
as an iron man variant and he replies
with he's not in it to my understanding
but i would love to see it but obviously
with everything take everything with a
grain of salt but according to these
leaked images at least i do think it's
fake but again you may be pleasantly
surprised and tom cruise may have a
cameo in upcoming film but nevertheless
take with a grain of salt and i guess we
just have to wait to the film until we
find out unless if i tease him in an
upcoming trailer for the film which
apparently we actually meant to get a tv
spot for doctor strange to on the super
bowl so if that's true i'm looking
forward to that and i'm curious to see
how much of the film they're going to
show are they going to show a lot or
they're going to take an approach which
they did for no way home and not show
too much you know if that harvard way
that's pretty much everything for this
video guys so please let me know in the
comment section below if you think this
rumor is fake or real let me know and if
you haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching